Gwyneth Paltrow has spent plenty of time
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe but her
memory seemed to be a little shaky the
Academy award-winning actress who played
Pepper Potts opposite Robert Downey jr.
Tony Stark across seven Marvel movies
has admitted that she hasn't seen many
of the Marvel movies she's been in
particularly 2017 spider-man homecoming
she spilled the fact to late-night host
Jimmy Kimmel during a recent interview
Paltrow made waves regarding her small
role in homecoming for which she
received top billing even beating out
zendaya for the fourth credit after she
infamously argued with MCU co-star Jon
Favreau during the inaugural episode of
his Netflix series the chef's show about
whether or not she was in the movie
Paltrow in fact seemed a little confused
about the entire situation but it was
undeniably funny when she insisted that
she never appeared in homecoming
despite fab Roe's assurances that she
definitely did you were in spider-man no
yeah I was in Avengers Avengers Iron Man
also her confusion makes a degree of
sense Marvel is famously secretive about
the content of its upcoming films even
altering trailer footage to throw fans
off the scent actors appearing in Marvel
Studios films don't always know the
details of the movies therein either
for example brie Larson confessed she
didn't know she was in Avengers endgame
until she got to the set during her
appearance on Jimmy Kimmel Live Paltrow
confessed that not only does she not
recall appearing in homecoming but she
also hasn't ever sat down and watched it
the reason why she simply got confused
because quote there are so many of these
wonderful Marvel interconnecting movies
and she thought that her role in the
spider-man movie was actually for one of
the Avengers films I never actually saw
the movie oh you didn't see them
in response Kimmel joked that he doesn't
expect the busy actress to stay
up-to-date on superhero movies even once
that she's in your witness paltry you
shouldn't be watching spider it it would
upset people
homecoming isn't the only Marvel movie
Paltrow has been in that she's never
even seen in an interview with el
Paltrow revealed that she skipped
watching a lot of Marvel movies since
the franchise is so big there are so
many superheroes to keep track of and
she has other priorities in life her
confusion and busy life has led her to
not watch very many Marvel movies which
in turn has made Paltrow totally forget
which MCU films she starred in she told
the magazine it is confusing because
there are so many Marvel movies and to
be honest I haven't seen very many of
them it's really stupid and I'm sorry
but I'm a 47 year old mother this isn't
the first time the Marvel star has
appeared confused about the cinematic
universe she's a part of she's forgotten
Sebastian Stan aka Bucky Barnes multiple
times having asked who Stan was on a red
carpet and getting called out by Stan
himself in an Instagram post after he
introduced himself to her three separate
times and Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige previously spilled that Paltrow
was asking why Sam Jackson was there
when they were filming a scene for
Avengers and game together he recalled
the other actors were jumping in saying
what are you talking about he's Nick
Fury you've been in movies with him
during the same Kimmel interview in
which Paltrow told the truth about
whether or not she'd bothered to watch
spider-man homecoming she was also
caught off-guard when presented with
products from her lifestyle brand and
online steward goop which sells
everything from martini bath salts to a
water bottle that has an amethyst inside
of it for some inexplicable reason
throughout Kimmel's presentation Paltrow
seems positively puzzled over the vast
majority of the products leading viewers
to wonder if she's ever looked at dupes
inventory at all apparently it's really
from Kimmel are you gonna try some it
might seem absurd that Paltrow forgets
everything from her acting credits to
her own merchandise but at the very
least the star is providing plenty of
amusing press clips for her huge variety
of projects such a huge variety
fact that it seems impossible for her to
remember them all check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the MCU are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bells so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]